[Music]
all right let's go to noah in san
francisco what's up noah how are we
doing
hey dawg dr john doing good how are you
doing good brother what's going on dude
yeah so i'm calling you today because i
would like to get your advice on a
situation that we're dealing with cool
bring it on uh so
my beautiful stepdaughters turned five
and she's gotten to the age where she
has realized that me and her biological
dad have never met okay
and being a curious five-year-old she
asked him about it and he told her that
we have never met and that
he won't ever meet
me and did he tell her why or just that
he wouldn't
just that okay
and now she's asking us about it and
we're not really sure how much
information she can handle what should
we tell her
you tell her the truth don't ever ever
ever ever lie to your kids
so do you want to see this guy
for her sake i do you know when she gets
older and starts having you know school
events sporting events i would love for
all of us to be able to sit together and
enjoy these things you know for her sake
have you ever reached out to this dude
we've well
through my wife we've tried i've never
personally tried i don't have his phone
number but
we've tried and he just refuses to
so i want you to reach out to him
somebody's got to go first
okay
i want you to be the dad in this
situation i want you to be the the man
in this situation i don't want to gender
it but i want you to be the adult in
this situation
i want you to reach out to him because
y'all are sharing parenting of a
five-year-old little girl
and that's bigger than you being scared
of him him being a acting like a
what a bratty little kid
pisses me off quite honestly like it
makes me mad because there's a little
girl that's suffering at this deal and
i'm not mad at you dude but um i want
you to to
lean in hard on this deal and say hey we
need to go have coffee because we're
co-raising a daughter together
and we need i want to go have coffee
with you man i want to go grab a drink
and i know it's going to be awkward i
know it's going to be hard i know it's
going to be whatever but for the sake
this little girl i'd love to meet with
you and i'd love to map out a plan so
that you and i are on the same page
and i want you to reach out and do that
and if your wife says no you can't talk
to there's that's a problem okay because
y'all are all in this together
and when you married her
you didn't marry him but he's in your
life that's what you signed up for
and whenever they got divorced then he
signed up for there being other people
and at some point he's going to get
remarried and whoever he gets remarried
to is going to be a part of this picture
too so adults have to be adults and
y'all got to get in this thing together
if he won't
if he says you know
screw you dude i'm not meeting with you
you know whatever whatever whatever
um then when your daughter says well why
won't you ever why can't you and daddy
whatever um say we are working on it and
sometimes adults
have hard feelings too but we're working
on it and let that be that
and i want you to circle back every six
months hey brother just checking in man
any chance we could get together talk
about um talk about
whatever your daughter's name is
okay and here's what here's what's gonna
happen in 10 years when she's 16 or 17
one of two things will happen you and
that dude will have made peace with the
world you have decided to put her ahead
of y'all's ego
your wife will be in it too and the fact
that she made a child with another dude
she's not just make peace with that
guy's gonna be part of her life forever
um yeah well either a all three of you
be sitting by each other at a band
concert or in the same room or whatever
or at a track meet or whatever is going
on
or you're gonna be able to sit down with
your 15 year old daughter and say hey
i'm just gonna show you this
here is a track record of the last 10
years
of me reaching out
okay i want you to know that i love you
your mom loves you
your dad loves you
your other dad loves you um
we've we've just struggled making
relationships with each other has no
reflection on you whatsoever it's not
about you it's about adults not being
able to get our crap together and i'm
sorry
okay but that's not for years
is that cool
yeah
i like the idea of you know setting a
track record something to show her you
know because that's what i'm worried
about you know when she gets later in
life i don't want her to have any type
of feeling or resentment you know
towards that situation it's it's gonna
be less that it's gonna be more
you've got adults speaking into a 15 16
17 year old
almost adult
telling her life things and here's what
she should be doing and here's what a
wisdom and adulthood looks like
and she's gonna have cognitive
dissonance because she's gonna be
witnessing the adults in her life acting
like little babies
does that make sense
and so you're gonna be able to provide
her with a picture of hey i've tried to
control what i could control
and i couldn't bring us all together i
tried your mom's gonna do the same thing
i tried but all three of us love you
crazy
and so all three of us were at the
theater performance we just sat in
different places
and
the
my hope is you keep chipping away at
this dude and he's gonna say you're
right
did their marriage end badly did she
cheat on him or something like what's
his deal
um it ended with some physical violence
very poorly but their relationship has
gotten a lot better over the last four
years which is unfortunately ours has
yet to start so this dude just sucks
yeah pretty much okay so he may be
like if if he's
if he's an abusive
egomaniac idiot loser he may not be able
to have the courage or
the um maturity
to put his daughter's needs first if
he's the kind of guy that will go hit a
woman he may just be such a spineless
coward
that um he can't put his ego aside
maybe he lost everything including his
daughter including his wife and he
changed
and maybe he's tried to maybe he's
growing up right that's what i'm hoping
for
and you putting an olive branch out
there um
might be an a measure of grace to a guy
who's trying to change his life because
he blew it he lost everything right
and um that may be really
incredible
but that that starts with you okay i
wouldn't put that on your wife she's
been abused by this dude she's been
burned by this dude this is the dad of a
stepdaughter okay
are you scared to do that
no not at all you know i i would like to
have a relationship with him you know
because he's the
father of my stepchild you know i love
her so much and i you know like i said
in the future i want to be able to have
something stable for her you know when
she gets older that's right so um do it
cause it's right and it's gonna be so
hard um the excuse well i don't have his
number man that's not an excuse that
that should end in about eight seconds
um send him an email that he can write
it i sent him an email and um you all
get onto this right away and at least
make him send him an email and then a
text hey brother i sent you an email
this is so and so this is noah i sent
you an email um
read it and give me a shout
and if he writes you back i blocked you
whatever then y'all deal with that then
but i don't
i don't know dude i'm so optimistic that
people get you know just need some
connection but i know that's not always
accurate and right but um do the right
thing man do the right thing on behalf
of her on behalf of your marriage i'm
half everybody okay do it on behalf of
this guy even though if he doesn't
deserve it reach out for me